hey there guys thanks tuning in just a
quick one today I want to talk to you
about a supplement I've been using and
I've been having a lot of luck with its
cordyceps sinensis and it's pretty weird
it's something that you don't often hear
about in nootropic or bodybuilding
circles and that's why I'd like to
highlight it in this video because I
think for me has been working pretty
well
[Music]
okay so with any supplement it's always
very difficult to know if you're getting
a placebo effect or if you're getting
some genuine effects that are coming
from the product itself that's the case
with this one it's the case with
everything I've pretty much ever taken
except for weight protein in this case
though for me personally I think there's
a strong possibility that it's certainly
being doing something and I think most
likely that something is improving my
energy levels improving my motivation my
ability to work for long periods without
distraction and my ability to recover
from workouts and general stress it's a
supplement that athletes take for
endurance training as well as for things
like recovering from adrenal fatigue and
overtraining and the research
surrounding it is really very
interesting and yes enough but it's
convinced to me and that's really rare
actually because a very cynical guy so
what it is is like I say super weird
it's a mushroom a fungus that grows out
of the heads of dead caterpillars in the
himalayas so that's probably know what
you expecting me to say fortunately they
found a way to synthesize this in the
lab because that would obviously be
quite expensive if the only way you can
get it is out of the tops of the heads
of dead Casper's the legend goes that it
was the goat herders in the Himalayas
who've discovered quarter steps first
when they noticed that their livestock
the goats they were eating the cordyceps
as it grew and becoming more virile more
strong and generally healthier so they
thought this was interesting and they
started to take it themselves and it
quickly became popular as a as an
aphrodisiac for men it then came to
popularity again came to the spotlight
when it was used by the Chinese women's
Olympic long-distance running team and
they broke all these records apparently
and eyebrows were raised people thought
it might be steroids so they looked into
this and apparently it wasn't steroids
and what the coach of the team said was
that actually it was down to cordyceps
you know I was going to say that cuz
otherwise that would be an unrelated
story so that's all obviously not very
scientific but as anecdotal evidence
it's cool and it's interesting and then
when they looked into how
works and they found that it potentially
does have the same effects that they
were finding it's got tons of bioactive
agents it's an antioxidant it's very
good for your general health that's not
what I'm interested in I'm interested in
the fact that according to a lot of
research it can increase the amount of
ATP that's adenosine triphosphate in
your blood ATP being the most basic form
of energy you should know this if you've
been reading the bionaire or watching
this channel for a while it's the most
basic form of energy that your body
converts things like glucose into to use
so that's interesting and that's why
I've been stacking it with creatine
creatine of course recycles used ATP
using creatine mono phosphate and that
allows you to get more use out of your
existing ATP so if you theoretically
were to take cordyceps and stack that
with creatine then you'd not only have
more ATP to begin with but you'd also be
recycling more of that ATP and reusing
it so that's the theory and again
something I've been finding quite
effective I don't know anyone else who
stacks those two things together that
was my own idea and yeah like I say it's
working well so give it a try if you're
interested it's also supposed to be
effective at increasing oxygenation in
the blood possibly through vasodilation
in other words it allows more oxygen in
gets around your body more and helps you
to burn more calories as well as running
further and generally being more aerobic
ly efficient which would explain
theoretically why a Chinese Olympic team
might be able to run much longer without
tiring out it's been shown to help
people recover from as I said adrenal
fatigue and overtraining and one way it
might do this is by raising testosterone
and lowering cortisol the testosterone
cortisol ratio in your blood is one
indicator that people use to detect
whether song might be over trained or
not and cordyceps can apparently raise
your testosterone quite effectively
which would explain why in traditional
Chinese medicine it's used to raise a
virility in men studies have shown this
to be quite effective they haven't
really been carried out in human
subjects but in mice and in vitro
studies it's been found to boost
testosterone by as much as two hundred
percent in some cases which is a fair
amount more than a lot of the
ingredients that you found in all these
testosterone boosters that'll raise
testosterone by about 30% however for
some reason cordyceps you know the
supplement market hasn't jumped on it
yet as a potential bodybuilding
ingredient whether or not that's likely
to correlate with humans in reality you
know we might need larger doses than
they used in those studies etc is
unknown but in my experiences like I say
I've been feeling just generally more
varieties on cordyceps some of them show
that it's very effective at improving
the swimming ability of mice in a long
distance in increasing the athletic
performance of elderly people etc than
other studies suggest that it doesn't
work there's one study on cyclists I
think that found that they weren't able
to cycle any further or any faster so as
usual the evidence is up in the air but
there's enough to me there's enough
interest around this and enough
anecdotal evidence and enough supporting
evidence even from the research but it's
certainly something that's interesting
to me in Chinese medicine it was also
supposed to raise just Chi you know Chi
being the Chinese idea of a life force
it's used in martial arts and in certain
healing practices and you know something
scientifically shaky grounds but the
point is that Chi represents someone's
health and they're just general vitality
so you know if you're stressed and
rundown then in theory something like
this can help me to recover and go for
longer without just you know you're
burning out and that's what I found
because I recently moved house and I was
trading very hard at my work being
picked up and I think I had reached a
burnout so my training was affected and
the amount of work I was doing was
affected and of course this might just
be coincidence and I might have just
recovered naturally but I think that
taking cordyceps and stacking it as I
have done with creatine and also DAA
which I talked about in my testosterone
video has helped me to get my mojo back
basically I wake up in the morning and
I'm able to do a workout whereas
normally it takes a couple of hours to
come around and shrug off the sleep
inertia at the end of the day after you
know 10 hours of working I'm still able
to stay focused and productive instead
of starting to procrastinate as I get
tired and then I can maybe fit in
another workout in the evening to
obviously it could just be a placebo but
it seems to be working for me so I don't
want to change anything as it's quite
cheap and as the studies are quite good
maybe you could check it out too so let
me know in the comments section below
what you think are you going to give
this supplement a go is it something
you've already tried what your
experience is I'd love to hear about it
so yeah please let me know what you
think if you found this video useful
interesting then please consider liking
and sharing maybe subscribing to the
channel means a great deal to me and for
all those of you who already subscribed
then thanks a ton for supporting this
channel because it means a great deal to
me this is really my passion and stick
around because I've got all the usual
stuff coming soon fitness training
bodybuilding productivity nootropics
bruce lee you name it so if that sounds
good then i'll see in the next video and
until then hope you have a great
December bye for now